[Music]
before you made it big you were a Berber
shop model yeah one commercial you what
does that mean you a barbershop model
use every curls you had jheri curl and I
was on the East Coast
yeah so yeah that was when I got my
first break and you know being on a post
or someone actually because I got a
pretty fancy yeah we have we actually
have things look at this profile
beautiful very commanding you don't
laugh at that we have I know my
instrument mm-hmm that's your instrument
feel my face look and this yeah we got
that look at this picture here this is
what we this was from when you were so
pretty you were very pretty
I should have floated like a butterfly
and sting like a bee what about in the
past you and I have talked and you've
expressed different feelings about
President Obama as well I am you've said
different lease by President Obama how
you feeling about President Obama these
days um just do me off when I seen him
get interviewed by Steve Harvey and I
like Steve Harvey I think he's great but
it just threw me off when I seen him do
a one-on-one with Steve Harvey and I
said to myself like why is my president
getting interviewed by the host of
family few diplomas right yeah all right
you're an international celebrity from
30 rock that shows shown all around the
world how does your stand-up now and you
travel to other countries how was it
received well I would I toured Australia
last summer for two weeks and uh I got
you know sort of promiscuous on stage I
talked about sex and it's one lady
tweeted out that I she said Tracy Morgan
is gonna change the way men look at
women and I said wait a minute you got
to look at the porn industry for that
they make like 8 billion dollars a year
I don't get the Dom of it you know how
much Jake the way people see people I
don't know no I'm not yeah I love sex I
think it's fun I think we should enjoy
more than not taking so serious you know
a minute look at me man I remember one
time I was making love to this girl and
she started laughing at me
so I started laughing with are you
digging a little imagine how I feel
[Laughter]
myself that serious yeah this is in a
different industry if I did